¿Tienen los Estados Unidos que lanzarse a
una guerra comercial? ¿Está la economía
norteamericana en peligro por el gigantesco
déficit comercial que arrastra cada año?
¿Está China compitiendo de forma desleal?
¿Cómo puede Donald Trump proteger y defender
a
los Estados Unidos?
Amigos, una cosa son las intenciones…. y
otra muy distinta los resultados.
Eso es precisamente lo que pasa casi siempre
con las políticas proteccionistas: pretenden
una cosa, pero consiguen otra muy distinta.
Donald Trump fue claro durante la campaña
electoral que le llevó a la Casa Blanca….
y lo ha seguido siendo desde que ocupa el
Despacho Oval: las políticas proteccionistas
son una fantástica idea.
(8 de marzo: “Trump anuncia la imposición
de aranceles a las importaciones de acero
y aluminio, excluyendo a Canadá y México”.
Europa Press.)
(22 de marzo: “Trump anuncia la imposición
de aranceles por casi 50.000 millones a las
importaciones chinas”. Europa Press)
(6 de abril: Trump amenaza a China con imponer
aranceles por otros 100.000 millones de dólares.)
De momento solo están aprobados los primeros,
los aranceles al acero y al aluminio, y se
ha excluido a muchos de los países aliados.
Pero a tenor de las noticias… si algo es
seguro es que Trump tiene claro, clarísimo,
que una de sus grandes prioridades es la “lucha”
contra el déficit exterior, es decir, reducir
la diferencia entre las importaciones y las
exportaciones.
Una diferencia que supera los 500.000 millones
de dólares cada año.
[Y ahí es donde entra siempre entra en juego
el recurso a los aranceles. Algo así como,
Ey, ¿qué mi gente quiere comprar productos
extranjeros? No importa, ya verás como aprenden
a golpe de arancel]
Ahora bien, seamos justos.
Son muchos los que defienden que no es que
Trump quiera meterse de lleno en una guerra
comercial, sino que todas estas amenazas del
presidente de Estados Unidos, especialmente
hacia China, no son más que un órdago, una
forma de obligar al gobierno de Xi Jinping
a sentarse en la mesa y negociar.
Y sí, puede ser, que así sea.
Pero como con Trump nunca se sabe, por si
acaso y para tener las cosas claras, creo,
amigos, que tenemos que hacernos algunas preguntas:
¿Le conviene a los Estados Unidos abrir fuego
y comenzar una guerra comercial? ¿Son los
aranceles la mejor forma de ayudar a la economía
norteamerica? ¿Está China infringiendo las
normas? ¿Está compitiendo de forma desleal?¿Hay
que castigar a Pekín?
Veámoslo.
(UN MAL PLAN PARA NINGÚN PROBLEMA)
Amigos, os hago una pregunta, ¿Qué pretende
un político cuando pone sobre la mesa políticas
proteccionistas?
[No, ganar votos no es una respuesta válida.
Sí,sí, ya lo sé, ganar votos es la prioridad
número 1 de prácticamente todos los políticos,
pero por eso mismo… no hagamos trampas,
centrémonos en los objetivos específicos
de las políticas proteccionistas.]
Pues… creo que podemos decir que los objetivos
suelen ser: defender los empleos industriales,
castigar una supuesta competencia desleal
[generalmente por parte de países más pobres]
e impulsar la economía local.
Ahora bien… esas son las intenciones…
¿pero los resultados? ¿Si Estados Unidos
desata una guerra comercial con China va a
lograr esos objetivos?
Pues, amigos, vayamos por partes:
En primer lugar, esto es lo que dice Donald
Trump:
(“Bajo mi Administración, el robo a la
prosperidad americana terminará. Vamos a
defender nuestra industria y crear unas reglas
de juego igualadas para el trabajador americano.
Donald Trump”
Under my Administration, the theft of American
[Wow, menos mal que están los políticos
para defender al pueblo norteamericano…
Por cierto, esta es la misma excusa que utiliza
para perseguir la inmigración, defender al
trabajador estadounidense. Solo hay un problema:
Los datos muestran una realidad muy diferente.]
(El mercado laboral de los Estados Unidos
vive su mejor momento en casi dos décadas.
La tasa de desempleo se sitúa alrededor del
4% y el número de vacantes sin cubrir, ojo,
crece como la espuma.
La máquina económica norteamericana está empezando a sufrir desabastecimiento
del input más importante de todos: la mano
de obra.)
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Si no cambia la política migratoria, ni la
economía se viene abajo, claro, se calcula
que en los próximos 10 años los Estados
Unidos tendrán más de 8 millones de puestos
de trabajo sin cubrir.
Esto es algo que está ya ocurriendo de forma
bastante intensa en el medio oeste, en estados
como Wisconsin, donde hay mucho empleo pero
pocos trabajadores:
(“Es genial tener más puestos de trabajo
que nunca antes en Wisconsin, pero crea un
desafío: sólo necesitamos más gente”.
Tricia Braun, Directora de Operaciones de
la Agencia de Desarrollo Económico de Wisconsin.)
En estos momentos la tasa de paro en este
estado está por debajo del 3%... y los nuevos
empleos no paran de surgir.
(Por ejemplo, el grupo taiwanés de tecnología
Foxconn, está invirtiendo más de 10.000
millones de dólares en un gigantesco campus
para desarrollar y producir nuevas pantallas
para smartphones, tablets y televisiones.
Dará empleo a más de 13.000 personas.)
La situación es tan curiosa que las autoridades
del estado se han visto obligadas a poner
en marcha una campaña de publicidad, por
ejemplo en los trenes de Chicago y aquí mismo
en YouTube, para atraer trabajadores al estado.
Pero… no solo eso….
Vereis, es verdad, que la industria manufacturera
da empleo hoy a mucha menos gente que hace
2 décadas, pero, ¿Qué pensais? ¿Es culpa
de la competencia china?
(Pues los datos nos dicen otra cosa…. no
solo el empleo está en los niveles más altos
de la historia en la economía de los Estados
Unidos, sino que además la propia producción
industrial está también en sus niveles más
altos.
Sí, la industria contrata a menos personas,
pero eso no quiere decir que produzcan menos.
Lo que ocurre es que las fábricas, gracias
a los robots y a la tecnología, son cada
vez más productivas.)
Por ejemplo, echemos un vistazo a la industria
siderúrgica, la que Trump ha dicho esta amenaza
de muerte por la competencia china, lo que
supone un peligro para la seguridad nacional…
bueno, pues la realidad es que EEUU produce
el 70% del acero que consume, que apenas el
3% es para uso militar [¿Seguridad nacional?
Ja] y que, además, China no está ni siquiera
entre los 10 primeros proveedores.
Sí, el empleo en la industria siderúrgica
se ha reducido a casi la mitad en los últimos
10 años, pero amigos, la inmensa mayor parte
de los puestos de trabajo perdidos no se deben
a China ni al comercio internacional, sino
a la tecnología.
Y esto… una guerra comercial no lo cambiaría.
Pero… como veis tampoco es algo precisamente
malo: hoy, en los Estados Unidos, hay más
empleo que nunca y el déficit comercial…
bueno, a pesar de lo que diga Trump no es
tan alto, supone menos del 3% del PIB… y
de hecho se ha reducido bastante en los últimos años.
Además nos estamos olvidando de otros detalles…
por ejemplo, de las inversiones.
(Estados Unidos tiene un saldo de inversiones
netas positivo. Es decir, los extranjeros
invierten más en Estados Unidos que los norteamericanos en el extranjero,
algo que evidentemente es
muy bueno para el futuro de la economía estadounidense.
En 2017 este saldo positivo superó los 250
mil millones de dólares.)
Ahora bien, ¿Pensáis que aquí acaba todo?
Pues estáis muy, pero que muy equivocados.
Una guerra comercial… no sabemos si reduciría
el déficit exterior… pero tendría otras
consecuencias no precisamente deseables. Atentos.
(LAS CONSECUENCIAS)
Digámoslo claro, los mayores afectados por
una guerra comercial contra las importaciones
chinas serían las propias empresas de los
Estados Unidos.
Tal cual como lo escucháis. Comprar inputs
más baratos en el extranjero reduce los costes
de producción de las industrias locales,
[y si además, un país extranjero, en este
caso China, vende por debajo de coste, eso
es como si Pekín subvencionará a las industrias
norteamericanas. Y eso no suena tan mal, ¿verdad?]
¿No me creeis? Pues fijaos.
(Estados Unidos no solo importa de China productos
para consumir, también importa muchos bienes
intermedios y bienes de capital, como maquinaria,
por ejemplo. De hecho, más de la mitad de
todas las importaciones desde China se corresponden
con este tipo de productos.)
¿Y que conseguirían los aranceles?
Pues precisamente, dañar la competitividad
de las empresas norteamericanas.
Encarecer el coste de producción de bienes mucho más
avanzados, donde hoy la industria norteamericana
es líder… lo que supondría reducir sus
exportaciones al resto del mundo,
y también la capacidad de consumo de los propios estadounidenses.
¿El resultado? Millones de empleos perdidos.
Por ejemplo… el nuevo arancel sobre el acero
o el aluminio hará que la producción - en
Estados Unidos, ojo - de cosas que utilizan
acero y aluminio -, como los coches o los
aviones sea más cara… y por tanto menos
competitiva…
[¿Tendrán que fijarse nuevos aranceles a
los coches para compensar este mayor coste
de producción local?]
(Esto, amigos, es lo que explica que cuando
en 2002 el entonces presidente George W. Bush
impuso aranceles al acero importado, el saldo
final fue de un total de 200.000, 200.000
puestos de trabajo destruidos. Vamos, que
el tiro salió por la culata)
Pero es que, además, hay otro detalle muy
importante: cuando tú fijas aranceles, lo
normal es que la otra parte se defiende. No
digo que esté bien, pero ocurre.
("Si los Estados Unidos anuncian una serie
de nuevos aranceles por valor de 100.000 millones,
China ya se ha preparado completamente, y
no va a dudar en hacer un duro contra ataque”)
Imaginemos por ejemplo el caso de Boeing.
China es el mayor mercado para esta compañía,
en los próximos años entregará cientos
de nuevos aviones.
Pues bien, una guerra comercial podría dañar
su posición competitiva a largo plazo.
China por ejemplo, podría favorecer a otras compañías
como Airbus y acelerar el desarrollo de una
industria local. Sí, hoy por hoy parece algo
difícil… pero a largo plazo las consecuencias
podrían ser enormes.
Y no solo eso. China podría recurrir también
a otros medios menos ortodoxos. Por ejemplo,
no olvidemos que China es el mayor propietario
extranjero de deuda de Estados Unidos.
¿Sería bueno para Washington que China dejará
de comprar deuda o que incluso empezará a
reducir sus títulos como deuda de presión?
La respuesta claramente es No. Mucho menos
con el enorme déficit público que está
alimentado la actual administración.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque hay algo
en lo que Trump si tiene razón.
¿ESTA CHINA ROMPIENDO LAS REGLAS?
En una cosa Donald Trump está en lo cierto: China no es precisamente un
mercado libre ni un país que juegue del todo
limpio.
Y no solo se trata solo de que en muchos casos
tenga aranceles más altos o favorezca a las
empresas locales… lo más grave, por ejemplo,
es el chantaje que realiza a las grandes multinacionales.
(Si las empresas extranjeras quieren vender
libremente en China, tienen que aliarse con
socios locales… socios que tienen acceso
a la tecnología…
Sí, esta transferencia tecnológica supone
en cierto modo un problema, porque estas empresas
chinas la utilizan para crecer y competir…)
Claro que las empresas tecnológicas saben
dónde se meten a cambio de acceder al mercado
chino.
Tienen que ser ellas, las que decidan donde
producen, cómo compiten y que negocios realizan.
Eso sí, esto no quiere decir que el gobierno
de Estados Unidos no tenga que presionar y
negociar con China… pero, ojo, desatar una
guerra comercial sería una solución terriblemente
mala.
Mientras solo sean amenazas… pero mucho
cuidado con cruzar la línea roja. Así comienzan
las grandes crisis. Por fortuna, salvo que
Trump se empeñe, parece que eso no va a ocurrir:
(“China denuncia a EE UU ante la OMC y anuncia
más apertura comercial” Cinco Días.)
Ahora bien, dicho todo esto, un momento, porque
queda una pregunta sobre la mesa por contestar,
¿cómo puede Estados Unidos reducir el déficit
comercial?
Pues la mejor forma para lograrlo es con apuestas
estructurales, hacer lo que hicieron grandes
potencias exportadoras como Alemania o Suiza:
Favorecer el ahorro - y por tanto la inversión
productiva a largo plazo -, reducir el déficit
público - que al sobrecalentar la economía
impulsa el consumo de importación - y mejorar
la competitividad de las empresas locales,
por ejemplo reduciendo la burocracia, favoreciendo
la atracción de talento - sí, la inmigración
- y bajando los impuestos, como hizo la última
reforma fiscal del Partido Republicano de
la que os hablamos en este vídeo.
Esos son los caminos… una guerra comercial
en cambio… es mala para todas. Y en cualquier
caso, el déficit exterior no tiene porque
ser algo malo. Todo depende de cuánto crece
la economía, para que se utiliza o qué ocurre
con la inversión, por ejemplo.
En fín amigos, así están las cosas.
Pero ahora, turno para ti, ¿Estás a favor
de poner aranceles a China? Déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte si aun
no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.